hey guys it's me in this video we're
going to talk about the quantity of
vegetables or a salad that you need to
consume now obviously this might be a
little too much and you might not want
to use a fork like this but I'm trying
to make a point here if we look at the
derivation of the word food in the
dictionary it comes from the word
nourishment nourishment so we food to
nourish our bodies or provide nutrients
that's the purpose of food so if we just
reverse engineer that and look at how
much food we have to eat to get those
nutrients then we can figure out the
quantities because our bodies require
they're called RDAs different nutrition
you know recommend dietary allowances or
daily amounts of nutrition you need to
sustain your body so you have vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals and
amino acids it's proteins and fatty
acids but where you get most of the
vitamins and minerals is the salad or
the vegetable family now if we take a
look at how much you need it's probably
a lot more than what you've been doing
let's just take potassium you need 4700
milligrams per day of potassium to run
the body and that's a someone of 200
pounds now if you're like half that way
you can get a bag with half of it but
let's take a look at one banana is about
300 milligrams so you can see 4700
milligrams
you would have to eat a tremendous
amount of bananas and all that sugar
will probably create a problem so the
question is how much salad or vegetable
do you need per day let's just talk
about salad you would need about 7 to 10
cups so maybe on a small person you need
5 cups and a large person you would need
10 cups now if we take a look at what a
cup means 1 cup equals 1 ounce this
salad right here is 16 ounces so this is
16 cups this one right here is 16 cups
of salad with 16 ounces so on average if
you're roughly about 180 pounds or I
don't know 150 pounds
one hundred two hundred pounds you're
gonna need about half of this a little
less than half of this or a little bit
more than half of this per day and I
know right now you're probably going
what that's a lot of salad well it's not
that hard because salad is easy to
digest let's say you do one for lunch
and do one for dinner and you're good I
have all my salad in one sitting my bowl
is half of this and I will put all the
salad on there and I'll just down at
lunch
and I'm good for the day of course I
have more vegetables than I really need
are actually require just because they
make me feel good but it really also
depends on the quality of vegetable if
iceberg lettuce you would have to have
probably like a tremendous amount of
iceberg lettuce but let's take a look at
a high density nutrient type salads this
is spinach and kale kale obviously has
tremendous amount other vegetables that
are in the cruciferous family like Swiss
chard even arugula is cruciferous all
those are very high in nutrients except
cabbage cabbage does not have a lot of
vitamin A I don't think it has any
vitamin A but it has a lot of vitamin C
some vitamin C but it also has a lot of
phytonutrients so those are additional
chemicals in you know vegetables that
give you way more nutrition than regular
vegetables so that would be a positive
thing but I'm just talking about
vitamins and minerals right now so
spring spring mix really is composed of
a lot of different plants
Rugel a' romaine spinach beet greens
Swiss chard red mustard all these
different incredible combination of
vegetables and also lettuce leaves and
plant leaves and cruciferous leaves this
is like a really high level thing to
consume so this is what I consume
because it has like a variety of a whole
bunch of things so I get my vitamins I
get my minerals and but you need a lot
of it you're going to need half of this
okay now other ones
this one has 11 ounces so maybe if you
had like 3/4 of this you'd be okay
now other they have smaller like squares
that you can do like I think that are
half of this they're like five ounces so
you know you can do one of those per
meal or per day depending on how big you
are but that is what you need to
maintain and run your body
potassium not just potassium manganese
and calcium and all these other
nutrients are in salad the other thing I
want to mention is that some people use
sprouts on their salad which is really
smart when teaspoon of sprout is equal
to 50 teaspoons of broccoli as far as
phytonutrients and those are those
cancer-fighting properties so you can
use sprouts various things as far as
dressings go it's very important to have
dressings without sugar or very low
sugars the Newman's Own only has I think
it's like one gram of sugar per
tablespoon or two tablespoons it's it's
not too bad but if you could make your
own that would be better or the use
olive oil and vinegar Rhett I'm not
concerned right now with the nitpicky
salad dressings the goal is just to get
this in your body more than just to
avoid something in salad dressing okay
it's just the the weight of the benefit
of this is huge
the other thing to put on the salad is
very important you don't want to put
croutons you don't want to put
cranberries why because they're sugar
filled and they're sweet you don't want
to put raisins you want to put fat on
your salad bacon bits feta cheese olives
olive oil all that's really important
because that allows you to pull the fat
soluble vitamins or pull the vitamins
out of the vegetable or the plant
because plants salad etc have they don't
have the fat soluble vitamins they have
precursors there are little things that
turn into the active form of the fats
type of vitamins so vitamin A for
example in salad has to be converted to
the active form if you add some fat to
your salad you will pull more nutrition
out of that salad so we don't want a
low-fat salad we want some fat on there
and I love feta cheese as far as other
things you can put on put anything else
you want it to just don't put fruit and
don't put sugar but you can put some of
these other things other cut vegetables
nuts and seeds and walnuts and pecans
and blue cheese and all that stuff so I
just wanted to kind of emphasize again
the volume of salad that you need is
probably more than you're consuming
you'll feel much better if you do that
so go ahead and start doing that and I
hope you will apply this information